now they from the White House tonight is
President Donald Trump mr. president
thank you so much for being with us
thank you very much young let me pick up
what I was just discussing with with
Lindsey Graham and that is Ferguson
happened under President Obama Vice
President Joe Biden same with Baltimore
Cambridge all these other incidents they
didn't have any reforms criminal justice
reform happened with you
historically black colleges funded more
money for a longer period of time that
was you as well and if I look at some of
the other opportunities owns you that's
also and you're always under attack but
then you came out with these reforms
let's talk about police reforms you
announced yesterday well we did and if
you look at the previous administration
and frankly many administrations they
did nothing on this and we did criminal
justice reform we did tremendous
opportunity if you look at the
opportunities we've given everybody but
the opportunity zones have been
incredible it's been one of the great
really one of the great things in terms
of investment in areas and in terms of
unemployment it's been incredible before
the Chinese plague came to us the
african-american if you look at the
african-american unemployment Hispanic
unemployment Asian unemployment women
everything we had the best unemployment
numbers in the history of our country
we're almost a hundred and sixty million
people working nobody has been close and
now we're doing it again you see the
numbers coming back very strongly but
you're right the previous administration
did nothing I talked a lot of the three
years we did an investigation and we've
been proven right every step of the way
on what Jo DeGeneres kind of shocked me
the first time he said dirty cops
because I have a lot of family members
that were in law enforcement including
my own parents in some form and you know
then I always said the 99% I have an FBI
button on on me where every night have a
CIA button for the good people of
intelligence you talked about the good
cops you know there's a report tonight
and Atlanta that the department is
experiencing a higher than usual number
of call-outs for the upcoming shift
tonight you've heard of the term blue
I opened the show with well who are you
gonna call if we defund the police or
eliminate the police that seems to be
getting momentum in the country that
scares me I don't like to know your
feelings on it well Joe was referring
when he said dirty cops I believe to
James Comey and he was right about that
one and mccabe in that group so he was
referring to them but you know it's a
different form it's a different uniform
and you know you have bad and you have
great do you have cops and police and
law enforcement they're great people and
that's the vast vast majority of them
and they do an incredible job and they
keep us all safe and they love their
country and they don't want to make any
mistakes but they're under siege there's
no question about that and we worked on
some things very closely with law
enforcement and a lot of it you had in
your show I noticed the other night you
had it on your show and whether it's the
cams you know the dash cam and the body
cam which is a camera basically very
sophisticated camera and other things we
have a lot of that in the in the bill
and it passed and it it's going to pay a
lot of things are happening right now
but I signed an executive order and a
lot of that is included in what the
Republicans put out today and the
Democrats all they do is complain you
know they complain but they've they've
done nothing they do nothing they want
to defund and they want to abolish they
want to abolish police departments and
that's what's going to be you know with
Biden if you look if he ever got in
you'd be abolishing police you could
just watch because he's not going to be
running anything people around him will
and they will be abolishing police
they'll be getting rid of you say your
second Amendment very quickly you will
not have a second Amendment and many
other things you won't have that you'd
like to have you know we're watching
what's unfolding in Seattle mr.
president the autonomous zone Chas chops
Summer of Love as the mayor refers to it
potluck spaghetti dinners you have
offered help to every governor that
needs it every mayor that needs it they
have outright rejected it in states like
New York cities like New York states
like Illinois cities like Chicago
and that includes Seattle where you know
city blocks now have been taken over and
by the way they built their own version
of a wall interestingly enough to keep
people out and you keep offering to help
and they keep rejecting that help and
it's really the governor and the mayor's
job but there might come a moment where
you might not have an option I assume we
would know when that moment exists why
do you think they keep rejecting your
hope because it seemed to work in
Washington DC in Minneapolis when they
did accept it because the governor of
the state of Washington is weak and the
mayor is weak and what they're doing is
setting a precedent that's never been
said before in this country and these
people that are taking over this
incredible piece of real estate are
obviously very good at real estate maybe
better than I was because they paid
nothing they just took it over and the
police are somehow told not to be there
I'm sure they do a good job and they
were told to do a good job I assume
they're properly trained but we would go
in there if they want us in and we will
take it back very quickly it should
never be allowed to fester like it's
festering right now it's disgraceful to
our country it's a disgrace let's talk a
little bit about your reaction to the
two big cases it seemed to be universal
condemnation as it relates to George
Floyd and your thoughts on what it was
the charges that went down in Atlanta
earlier today
well the George Floyd case nothing has
to be said I watched that I couldn't
really watch it for that long a period
of time it was over eight minutes and
who couldn't who could watch that but it
doesn't get any more obvious or doesn't
get any worse than that
and I think it's a different kind of a
case and that man has some big problems
there's no question about it the police
officer what he did and I haven't met
any because I deal with law enforcement
all the time and I just left a big group
of great the top sheriffs and law
enforcement people in the country and
nobody was sticking up for what he did
the event that
place yesterday was I thought it was a
terrible situation but you can't resist
a police officer and you know if you
have a disagreement you have to take it
up after the fact it was a very sad very
very sad thing and look you really you
take a look it was out of control the
whole situation was out of control I
heard today and just got a report that
the police officers lawyer said that he
heard a sound like a gun like a gunshot
and he saw a flash in front of him so
that's an interesting you know I don't
know that I would have necessarily
believed that but I will tell you that's
that's a very interesting thing and
maybe that's so they could have to find
out it's up to justice right now it's
going to be up to justice I hope he gets
a fair shake because police have not
been treated fairly in our country they
have not been treated fairly but again
you can't resist a police officer like
that and they ended up in a very
terrible disagreement and look at the
way it look at the way it ended very bad
very bad
you know Terry McCall off you you you
you talked about in your interview with
my colleague and friend harris faulkner
you talked about joe biden almost having
compassion on him a lot of ways terry
mcauliffe
actually said I'm fine with him staying
in the basement he only sees two people
a day is to body man I'm fine with that
which I think is a very unusual and
unique way to run for president of the
United States to me I think there are
legitimate questions as it relates to of
a mental alertness and well let's say
stamina and strength and acumen I would
argue just in the last three plus years
your job is probably the hardest job in
the world that I can see I believe that
to be true should that be an issue in
the campaign well I think it's going to
be an interesting issue and he's been in
the basement for a long time I think
he's really been running beautifully
he's not running his campaign people are
running
is campaign I see quotes all the time
that he said this he said that about me
and their long beautiful flowing
sentences I said sure didn't make that
statement and Joe doesn't even know the
CeBIT was made but they are leaving him
there and at some point he's going to
have to come out for air and I think
look we've done a great job we've done a
great job if you look back a few months
to an economy that was the greatest of
all time everything we had was at
records every every no matter whether
it's unemployment whether it's the stock
market and now you look at what we're
doing I'm doing it all over again that
we had to turn it off we would have lost
millions of people we did we turned it
off and now we've started up again and
we're gonna have an amazing year next
year we're gonna have a great third
quarter we just had the best jobs
numbers the biggest job gain in history
and we just had the biggest retail sales
numbers in history for the last month so
we're starting up and it's going to be
very very strong we're very close to a
vaccine even with it without it but I
will tell you we're very close to a
vaccine and we're very close to
therapeutics really good therapeutics
and but even without that I don't even
like to talk about that because it's
fading away it's going to fade away but
having a vaccine would be really nice
and that's going to happen so all these
protests have been going on for weeks
and talk about social distancing kind of
went away come almost completely from
what I can tell there were many people I
saw that we're not wearing masks and
even some of the politicians now that
are critical of you having a rally in
Oklahoma on Saturday now all of a sudden
they're saying that it wells may not be
safe I understand temperatures are going
to be taken I understand people that go
there signing a waiver I understand that
mass will be worn by people and even
distributed I think I read somewhere
maybe you should change the name of the
rally and call it a protest and maybe
they will say it's okay then yeah
well that's to the protests I mean the
protesters
and anarchists and terrorists and
looters and all of the people that were
marching on various locations over the
last couple of weeks that's died down
they've lost some energy that's good but
because many of them don't even know
what they're protesting frankly but you
look at that and and they were right on
top of each other large numbers pretty
large numbers and they were right on top
of each other and nobody complained when
you look at fake CNN its total fake to
fake news operation and its really like
an extension of the Democrat Party and
then you look at M s DNC which is DNC
Democrat National Committee and you look
at it and you see the way they talk
they'd ever mention that they don't talk
about it this is all you hear about
Oklahoma what we're doing we'll be in
Tulsa you have a great mayor and you
have a great governor governor state I
spoke to him yesterday they're so
excited about it that you have no idea
and we have had so many sign ups you
know there are lines of people now and
we won't be there for three days they
have lines of people right now trying to
get into the arena I mean they'll be
there they'll be early how many people
are early front rows how many people
signed up do you know over a million
people requested tickets well there's
just a hunger for the rallies and I
enjoy doing them but they enjoy it more
importantly than me I they injure me
gives energy to everybody and we have
tremendous enthusiasm if you look at the
polls we're way ahead of sleepy Joe in
terms of enthusiasm we have enthusiasm
like they've never seen before actually
and Joe has the lowest I hear enthusiasm
on record now they have a party and the
party believes that a lot of bad things
open borders sanctuary cities open
borders think of it supposing like attea
water we built we're up to 212 miles of
wall and this is serious wall and I'm
going to be at the wall very soon we're
going to celebrate over 200 but it's 212
miles now nobody is getting through and
very very few people are coming through
on our border we have a tremendous
border
think of it in Tijuana is one of the
most here one of Mexico's one of the
most infected places on earth and we
have a wall between Tijuana and San
Diego you know it's like a beautiful
very powerful wall and California is
very happy that we have it because they
wouldn't have any numbers they would
they would have numbers like you
wouldn't believe right now if we didn't
have that so we've done a great job we
were very early to the call as you know
because you have one person that reports
it but when we heard about it I made the
decision not to let people from China
come in we loved people from China but
they were having a tremendous problem
and at the end of January I said you
can't come in you can't come in and we
saved tens of thousands and everybody
even even our critics give me credit for
that but we saved tens of thousands of
lives and then I banned Europe from
coming in because Europe many of the
people that couldn't come here went to
Italy and they went to Spain and France
and we had a ban Europe and we did that
fairly shortly thereafter so we've been
very early in our testing has been
phenomenal and we came up with
ventilators that we're the kings of
ventilators were making thousands of
ventilators a week all our people have
was not one person that need that needed
a ventilator has not gotten one every
single person that needed a ventilator
got one and it's been incredible now
we're helping other countries because
it's hard to make they're expensive and
they're big in there they're very highly
complex and we're helping other
countries many other countries we're
sending them ventilators let me let me
ask you it was ten days after the first
identified case of corona in the US when
you had the travel ban we hadn't had a
quarantine in 50-plus years of my
understanding and then the subsequent
travel bans you will call racist
xenophobic hysterical fear mongerer that
that was ten days after the first case
here I'm told according to my sources
that everybody that was advising you
didn't think it was necessary the models
were wrong predictions were wrong all
the way around
I don't know why they've been so wrong
China lied
what made you at that moment make that
one decision because that seems critical
to me well I was seeing information that
China Wuhan in particular was very
heavily infected and I just said look
you know why are we doing this and let's
see and nobody knew anything about it at
that time we didn't know it affected the
elderly much more so than children
that's why we have to open our schools
in the fall the children the numbers are
very very small almost almost
non-existent and it's an incredible
thing their immune system is very strong
and so we have to get the schools open
and I'm sure they'll be open I think
most of them if people are doing the
right thing they're going to be opening
up schools you have to have it too much
of a strain in many ways and unfair to
the children but I just felt it was a
heavily infected area and how are we
letting people into our country nobody
knew that it was going to be that
contagious it's a highly contagious
there's been nothing like this since
1917 over a hundred years ago where
probably anywhere from fifty to a
hundred million people died probably
ended World War one because all the
soldiers they were there was so sick and
it probably that was the one thing it
ended World War one very likely but
nobody had any idea was going to be this
this kind of contagious it has been
really rough but we've learned a lot and
we're doing really great in the
laboratories and we're going to have a
we're gonna have a vaccine very soon
john bolton who worked for you has a
book and in that book he's claiming that
that you asked china for help with your
reelection your trade representative by
the way the US Trade Representative is
now just breaking came out with a
statement claiming that that is false
and denies it there were just recently
released documents tonight NAFA davitz
that says the NSC has determined that
the information in the manuscript is
classified as confidential secret top
secret levels according
the publication release of the room
where it happened would cause
irreparable harm because the disclosure
of instances of classified information
in the manuscript reasonably could be
expected to cause serious damage or
exceptionally grave damage to the
national security of the United States I
went back I think it was a month before
he was fired and I have a whole series
of articles I don't have time for a mall
in an interview with my my former fellow
colleague Greta Van Susteren Moulton
said I think one thing you could be sure
of this is just before he got fired his
president Trump's not going to make the
mistakes of prior administrations here
that succumb to the idea that if you
give them economic benefits you
automatically count on them following
through with their commitments he said
on your views on Russia the president
gets criticized for being soft on Russia
I'm still waiting to see evidence of
that he's authorized us to take very
strong action against election meddling
by anybody strong action against
intrusions into our information
technology systems by countries like
Russia China North Korea and Iran what
is your reaction to this charge in this
claim of the president and what now the
government is saying basically it's
compromising national security is way I
interpret that well first of all nobody
nobody has been tougher on Russia or
China than I have nobody even close
China's paying us billions of dollars a
year they never gave us 10 cents and
Biden's son walked away with a billion
and a half dollars to manage making
hundreds of thousands and millions of
dollars on it so nobody has been tough
on China and nobody has been tough with
Russia like I have and that's less than
the record books and it's not even close
the last administration did nothing on
either and then in terms of Bolton he
broke the law he was a washed-up guy I
gave him a chance
he couldn't get Senate confirmed so I
gave him an on Senate confirmed position
where I could just put him there see how
he worked and I wasn't very enamored he
went into the Middle East he was one of
the the big guns for let's go into Iraq
and that didn't work out too well and I
was against that a long time ago before
I was ever even thinking about doing
doing now but he was one of the people
wanted to go to Iraq when I asked him
about it I said recently I said you know
about a month in when he was about a
month in and I said what do you think do
you think you made a mistake there no I
don't think so I don't think so I said
explain that one so the terrible
terrible thing that he did but he broke
the law very simple I mean as much as
it's going to be broken this is highly
classified that's the highest sage it's
highly classified information and he did
not have approval let's come out now
very loud and very strong and I
appreciate ambassador light Iser in
front of the committee today on an
unrelated topic they asked him that
question one of our friends and the
Democrat Party was very nice to ask him
the question and then he said absolutely
not Trump was tough on China but
nobody's been tough like me
nobody's been tough like me on China we
take him in right now billions and
billions of dollars from China I gave a
lot of it to the farmers because the
farmers were targeted by China nobody's
ever done that wasn't a 500 billion for
just two years alone if I remember the
first part of the deal not insignificant
and all the other trade deals let me go
one thing that kind of was interesting
to me everybody knows your opinion on
the the anthem annealing and you've been
very outspoken about it but comments you
made on Colin Kaepernick about if he
deserves to play in the NFL if he has
the playing ability if he you know and
you're right he did start off by the way
as a great great quarterback I mean
actually amazing couple of years you say
didn't end up in terms of being as good
a player in some of his later years but
he said he has terrific his first two
years and then he wasn't playing up to
snuff you said the answer is absolutely
I would you know won't you know like to
see love to see him get another shot and
obviously he has to play well if he
can't no but you would like to see him
get another shot I found that
interesting is the ability look you know
he could only get it if he has the
ability they're not gonna lose games
because of you know wanting to be
politically correct or whatever term you
might why don't know that's politically
correct or the opposite but if he has
the ability look he was a great rookie
and his second year
was great and then after that he started
going downhill rather rapidly and then
he was out of football and then he
started suing everybody and I think he
made a lot more money doing that that he
did with football but it was if he if he
has the ability if somebody would take
him I think look I know a lot of these
owners if they had if they had somebody
that was going to win games they'll sign
him it doesn't matter who they are
they'll sign them and you know I don't
like also relatively another subject but
I figure it's your next question when
the national anthem plays and our flag
the Great American flag is raised you
should not be kneeling you should be
standing ideally with your hand on your
heart we're saluting but they should not
be kneeling they can protest enough and
I saw the NFL get very weak I saw drew
Brees as a warrior a great great
quarterback a fan of his I'm a fan of
his and I sort of make this beautiful
statement and then the next day he
retracted the state we talked about his
father and his grandfather fighting in
the war for our country our flag and
then the next day he retracted it I just
don't get that but you have to stand
when the flag goes up and I think
they'll lose a lot of fans and a lot of
support in the NFL had already happened
before I thought they learned their
lesson but I think it's going to happen
again and I was surprised at Roger Roger
Goodell that he would have done what he
did and made this statement that he made
nobody was even asking for it let me go
back to Kovan and the economic recovery
you did mention you know look just like
the coronavirus models predictions they
were so off base I mean shockingly so
but with all of that said and nobody
predicted you know they were predicting
I think it was a nine million job loss
in May and you ended up gaining 2.5
million then you had a record
retail sales at 18 percent we see that a
Gallup poll that you're doing better
even now on this issue than Obama ever
did at any point of his presidency how
worried about you are you about well we
know it's when not if in terms of hot
spots emerging and we've we've now been
dealing with them how
confident are you that we're able to get
on them quick enough so that we don't
ever find ourselves in a position again
to have to shut down you know a big
portion of the economy in the country
and that would be again the cure can't
be worse than than the disease right
well we'll get on it that's right my
original statement the Cure can't be
worse than the disease itself and we'll
get on it quickly we're working with 50
governors some of whom are really
outstanding like in Oklahoma as an
example we're working with the
governor's that were working with local
representatives and mayor's and we're
supplying them what they need including
the ventilators now we don't need any no
matter what we have that taken care of
we're we're in great shape to put out
the ice I used to call them the embers
or the the flames they flare up in
certain areas a little bit but I think
we'll put them out very quickly and we
won't be closing the country again we
won't be have to do that but at the
beginning I tell you if we didn't do
what we did we made all the right motion
we would have lost anywhere from
probably one and a half minimum they
have to understand that's ten times what
we're talking about now ten times think
of that with every with all the loss
multiplied times and that's at a minimum
and you could have gone up to three and
a half or more million people and that's
many times more so we closed it we also
learned a lot about it who would attacks
it attacks different people but it
doesn't attack the young as we said but
it does attacked senior citizens older
people especially if they have a problem
with their heart if they have diabetes
they get attacked violently by this
horrible disease China should have China
should have kept it where it was they
could have easily stopped it
they either lost control they either
suffered great incompetence something
happened or I don't know the worst thing
would be is if they knew this was going
to happen because other than just
tonight I heard and yesterday they it
hit Beijing to a certain extent and
we'll see what happens there
just hit Beijing but other than that
they've kept it inside and you know
except when it came to letting it hit
the rest of the world only a hundred
39 days till Election Day Reince Priebus
was on the show the other night saying
maybe you and Joe Biden he gets out of
his basement can have more than the
usual three debates that a president
would have would you like that and or do
you like it the way it is do you have
any fear that Joe's gonna try and duck
them we only have 30 seconds sir
yeah I would I would frankly like it I
can tell you'd like it as television
would like it your companies would like
it but I would like to do it I'm open to
whatever they want to do Shawn get the
word thank you sir for being with us we
appreciate it really troubling times but
we'll get through it we're Americans
thank you sir thank you very much